in the land of terrassa a remote region
of Indonesia cliffside effigies and
graves testified to a culture as
fascinated with death as ancient Egypt
funerals are the most important rituals
in their culture here in terrassa
beloved relatives receive their favorite
dishes three times a day even after they
are dead to Rajan's don't immediately
bury the body of a family member they
keep the embalmed corpse and treat it as
if it is still alive families here
prefer to wait until they can afford to
throw a lavish funeral and that may take
months even years
auguste Lamba is shopping for a gift for
the funeral of his great aunt I'm
looking for the pigs because I mean I'm
going to bring it to the funeral
ceremony was my auntie
a gooses great aunt mrs. mendon dolly
pong died almost a year ago ever since
her body has resided at her family home
even in her casket she is considered
sick not dead mrs. dolly pong was a
member of the noble class and had a
large influential family people here
believe her spirit demands a lavish
funeral relatives lift the massive
coffin which resembles a traditional
tirage and house they carry her almost a
mile from her home to the field where
her funeral will take place it takes
three hours for the funeral procession
to reach the ceremony field for her
family and friends this is the moment
when mrs. dolly pong spirit leaves her
body but her spirit will need help
reaching Paradise which they call Kuya
because of mrs. Dawley pongs noble
status her children are spending
thousands of dollars to give her a
proper funeral the event is so big and
elaborate the family has hired funeral
planners who managed ceremonies
everywhere from the gold leaf decorating
their mother's coffin to the hired
entertainers the family's wealth and
prestige are on display to Rajan's
believe that the more lavish the funeral
the easier it is for the soul to reach
paradise mrs. Dolly Ponte children want
their mother's spirit to have the same
status in Paradise that she enjoyed on
earth to that end they also plan to
sacrifice many water buffalo symbols of
wealth people here believe the more they
send with mrs. dolly pong the easier it
will be for me to enter paradise and the
more blessings her spirit will bestow
upon them before they are sacrificed
buffalo fights provide the funerals most
dramatic entertainment it's heavy
sometimes it's dangerous sometimes the
heat fever the time has come to send
mrs. dolly ponder transportation to
paradise
[Music]
the mourners sacrifice almost a hundred
Buffalo but the meat won't go to waste
Warners can take it home finally mrs.
dolly Punk's family and friends are
ready to bid farewell to her spirit the
family prepares her body for its final
resting place in a cliffside mausoleum
the family quietly enters the body they
sealed the tomb against grave robbers
nearly a year after her physical death
mrs. Dolly ponk finally rests in peace
and her community has forged new bonds
for the future